(light rock music)
- Now it's time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Seth!
- Speed Racist.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- Points!
Points.
Yeah, Rachel.
- Aladdin 2: The Return
of Jafar's Genital Warts.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points!
(dinging)
Yes, Seth.
- Aqua Teen Hunger Strike.
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Yes, points!
(dinging)
Kevin!
- Premature Muppet Babies.
(audience groaning)
(Chris laughing)
- (singing) Muppet premies!
(audience laughing)
They're just all
under the glass.
Yeah, way points, way points.
(dinging)
Seth.
- He-Man and the Masters of Sex.
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Yes, points!
(dinging)
Kevin.
- Thunder, Thunder,
Thunder (bleep)!
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
Meow, meow, snarf!
(Kevin laughing)
Meow, yes, Rachel.
- The People vs.
Larry Flinstones!
- Yes, points!
(audience laughing)
Yeah, Seth.
- Winnie the jew.
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Thomas.
- Urban Poon?
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points, sure, points.
(dinging)
Kumail.
- Angry Nerds, it's pictures
of you attacking pigs!
(audience cheering)
(Chris grunting)
- You're not a nerd,
Chris Hardwick!
Points.
(dinging)
Yes, TJ.
- Instagram-Mother.
(audience laughing)
It's Instagram pictures...
It's just Instagram pictures
of all those sweet grandmamas.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, points.
(dinging)
You know how I
like the dry ones.
(TJ laughing)
(audience groaning)
- Yeah!
- No!
Don't applaud it!
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Yes, Kurt.
- One Flew Over
the Poo-Poo's Nest.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points, points!
(dinging)
Amber!
- Sisterhood of the
Traveling Hot Pants.
- Yes, points!
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
Rhysie!
- Raiders of the Lost Asshole!
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- [Chris] Points.
(dinging)
Yes, Kurt.
- Teenage Mutant
Ninja I'm Turtle-ing.
(Chris laughing)
(audience groaning)
Yes!
- Said with a smile!
Points!
And you broke Amber Tamblyn!
- I got Amber, I got Amber.
- Quick, Rhysie,
somebody buzz in!
(dinging)
Yes, Rhysie.
- Indiana Jones and
the Ass Crusade.
(audience laughing)
- You're really stuck on that
film series right
now, yes, points.
(dinging)
Amber.
- There Will Be
Blood In Your Stool.
- [Chris] Yes, points!
(audience cheering)
(Chris laughing)
Amber.
- Rear Window.
- Yes, Rear Window!
That works on its own.
(dinging)
Points and Kurt.
- Inside Llewyn Davis.
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Amber] Oh, that
was really good.
(Kurt laughing)
- And Outside Llewyn Davis.
Points.
- Yeah, no kidding
that movie sucked.
(buzzing)
(laughing)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Yes, Blaine.
- Bret the (bleep) Man Shart.
(audience laughing)
- Points, points!
(dinging)
Patton.
- The Iron-Deficient Sheik.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points, points.
(dinging)
Yes, Patton again.
- Me!
- Yes, points, points.
(dinging)
Brian.
- Ultimate Wario.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, Wario reference!
Points.
(dinging)
Yes, Blaine.
- Stone Cold Eve Austin,
not Stone Cold Steve Austin.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, points, points.
(dinging)
Yes, Brian.
- Brooke Hogan.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- Points, points.
Patton.
- Bret Hart but with diarrhea.
- Yes, points, that'd
be a way worse wrestler.
(dinging)
Yes, Blaine.
- Tap Me Out Elmo.
(audience laughing)
- Points.
(dinging)
Brian.
- King Kong Ted Bundy.
(audience applauding)
- Yes, points!
(dinging)
Brian.
The Jizz!
(audience laughing)
(light rock music)